c'est attendant historique pour le
Caucase la république autoproclamée du
haut carabar va cesser son existence
d'ici au 1er janvier 2024 sa dissolution
a été annoncée ce jeudi 28 septembre par
un décret de son président sam Bell
sharamanian toutes les institutions et
organisations gouvernementales doivent
être dissoute au 1er janvier 2024 la
République du haut Karaba 16 son
existence l'annonce intervient une
semaine après l'offensive éclaire lancé
par l'Azerbaïdjan pour reprendre le
contrôle de cet enclave arménienne
officiellement sur son territoire lâché
par l'Arménie les forces armées du
haut-karaba avait dû déposer les armes
après 24 heures de combat ouvrant la
voie à une réintégration de la région
dans l'Azerbaïdjan mais craignant les
répressions azerbaïdjanaises la
population du okaraba a entamé un
véritable exode sur les 120 000
Arméniens qui peuplent l'enclave 65000
ont déjà vu la région ces derniers jours
notre analyse montre que dans les
prochains jours il n'y aura plus
d'Arméniens dans le haut Karaba c'est un
acte de nettoyage ethnique contre lequel
nous avions mis en garde la communauté
internationale cette petite région MONT
du Caucase peuplé en majorité
d'Arméniens avaient fait sécession de
l'Azerbaïdjan à la chute de l'URSS en
1991 sans être reconnu
internationalement depuis Bakou n'a
jamais caché son objectif de remettre à
la main sur le haut Karaba tandis que
l'Arménie a régulièrement mis en garde
contre les risques de nettoyage
ethniques en cas de prise de contrôle à
zézérie avec la reddition du haut Karaba
c'est 1500 ans d'histoire arménienne qui
sont menacées de disparition dans
l'indifférence de la Russie et des
puissances occidentales les Arméniens du
haut-karaba n'avaient pour eux que le
vieux principe wilsonien du droit des
peuples à disposer de même principe à
géométrie variable invoqués par les
Occidentaux en fonction seul de leurs
intérêts du moment
[Musique]